aquí en vilanova de la concisawa en Sao
Paulo Pedro Farías es abogado y tiene
una agenda apretada nada mis rutinas son
un poco
como explicártelo son un poco
irregulares sabes o sea me despierto por
las mañanas y hay veces que no sé hasta
cuándo estaré en la oficina y es que no
trabaja en cualquier sitio tiene su
despacho en la avenida brigadeiro faría
Lima el corazón financiero de la ciudad
más rica de Brasil Pues mira justo desde
aquí se puede ver dónde trabajo yo que
es en este centro financiero como veis
tras vivir una temporada en Cataluña
España Pedro volvió al país con las
elecciones a la vuelta de la esquina y
una campaña electoral altamente
polarizada básicamente el presidente se
le ocurre decir que había tensión sexual
entre él y unas chicas venezolanas de 14
años él es lo que se conoce como faría
limer la élite de las finanzas del país
donde la mayoría son hombres
es el típico la típica persona que
trabaja
con mercados aquí la polarización
también se siente y no es extraño ver
que una empresa y sus trabajadores
planeen votar por la misma opción aunque
no sea su favorita como en el caso de
Pedro que va a votar por Lula da Silva a
pesar de preferir a Simón y tavity
candidata del mdb estamos en nuestra
democracia está ante un peligro muy muy
significativo que es bolsonaro y no pero
en la avenida no piensan igual Jessica
zarina asesor financiero está decidido a
votar por Jair bolsonaro Aunque tampoco
sea su favorito no creo que sea la mejor
opción entre los candidatos pero yo creo
que es el menos corrupto de las dos
opciones que tenemos en el país muchos
de estos trabajadores tienen redes y se
conocen entre ellos y es que sus
opiniones tienen Mucho peso ya que
influencian a la opinión pública y
muchas veces ejercen como lobbies
la feria lima y sus trabajadores ayudan
a conseguir todos los recursos a
aconsejar a los gestores de esas
empresas la opinión de los que trabajan
Aquí acaba importando a los que toman
las decisiones
la élite de la ciudad más rica del país
es que afecta y funciona como espejo de
la sociedad brasileña